la ligne 18 arrivera à Versailles à
l'horizon 2030 et elle permettra à
Guyancourt comme un Versailles de
desservir des sites qui ont vocation à
accueillir de nombreux logements qui
permettront à toutes celles et ceux qui
sont des travailleurs de la première
ligne de la deuxième ligne de se loger
dans des conditions dignes
il s'agit de faire en sorte que
évidemment le passage de la ligne 18 ne
vienne pas mettre en difficulté les
activités quotidiennes des agriculteurs
que des solutions puissent leur être
trouvées et que par ailleurs les les
nuisances sonores soient réduites au
maximum
[Musique]
on va continuer à travailler sur la
réduction des nuisances sonores non
seulement autour de la ligne 18 mais
aussi en Vallée de Chevreuse et à tous
le noble il y a le sujet de la santé qui
doit aussi avancer puisque on a comme
dans beaucoup d'endroits en
Île-de-France des déserts médicaux qui
inquiètent beaucoup nos concitoyens puis
à les sujets de sécurité je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure le ministre de
l'Intérieur a annoncé cette semaine
200 brigades de sécurité de gendarmerie
pardon sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'était une promesse du président de la
République il a suggéré au maire des
Yvelines de lui faire des propositions
et je me ferai fort de porter leur voix
auprès de lui
[Musique]